[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar time resolved electron
microscopy synaptic ultrastructure
millisecond by millisecond with high
pressure freezing
i'm kayleigh bach of labyrinths and i
will be your moderator for today's event
this educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by leica microsystems to learn more
visit leica-microsystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd now like to welcome our speakers dr
shigeki watanabe associate professor of
cell biology at john hopkins university
and grant cusick phd candidate at john
hopkins university shigecki grant you
may now begin your presentation
okay so thank you so much for such a
nice introduction um and thank you all
for tuning in today i'm shigeki watanabe
an associate professor in the department
of cell biology
at johns hopkins and today
with my graduate student we are cusick
um
we are going to talk about high pressure
prison and how we are using this
technique to basically look at memphian
dynamics at the synapses using
electromicroscopy
and so this
talk is divided into two parts the first
part is going to be taught by um it's
going to be me talking about why we are
using electromicroscopy and then why we
have to use high pressure breathing
technique and the second part grant is
going to talk about how we are adding
the temporal dimensions into
electromicroscopy and then how we are
using this technique to basically
looking at how synaptic vesicles
actually move at the synapses and so um
yeah so let's uh get started and so i'm
going to start talking about why
electromicroscopy
and so you know as you know team is
believing and then this is totally true
and so if you just look at this
electromicrograph you know this is just
so beautiful right uh you can see how
the nucleus is organized in a cell and
how they're embedded within this
endoplasmic reticulum and you can see
the organization of all these things
that are found within the nucleus such
as nucleolus or you can see
heterochromatin organizations or even
the nuclear from nuclear pore
that you can see in this picture and so
this is just such a beautiful image and
then now with over the last 10 years you
know there was a big development in a
coordinated microscopy technique that
allows us to actually pinpoint where the
proteins are in these images as well and
so you can really localize where the
proteins are to the substance
structures that you can actually see in
electromicrobial and so this is one of
the example images that we had
back in 2011 uh basically uh capturing
super resolution microscopy technique
with the eem to basically look at where
the histone molecules are in this
particular case so you can really see
where the heterochromatin organization
where the heterochromatins are at the
nucleus
electromicroscopy is also great for
looking at the protein complexes and so
you can look at these sensory neurons in
cylinders in this case and you can see
these microtubules and then you can see
how the protofilaments are actually
organized
in this particular image and then as you
know that the proto pyramids um these
are
basically looking like this and if you
do
if you have to do
a 3d reconstruction of these images and
what you're going to see is that there's
a nice you can even look at the protein
complexes from these images as well
and so erectile microscopy can really
get down to the protein resolutions uh
especially with the cryo electron
tomography these days
and then electromicroscopy is also great
for what we are interested for looking
at what we are interested in and this is
the snapshot and so this is an example
image from ventral knob code of c
elegans um c elegans and you can see
this is the
um ventral nerve pull over here and
there's also a muscle uh on the right
side of the picture and then what you
see here is that there's actually a
motor neurons that control this muscle
movement and if you are zooming into one
of these images and this is what we are
just looking at and so here is the
synapse and these are neuromuscular
junctions and you see these uh circular
structures between this membrane um
within the membrane these are called
synaptic vesicles these contain
neurotransmitter and they are used
during the neurotransmission
and so what you can see here
as noted as dope synaptic vesicles here
they are actually touching the plasma
membrane they are in a close association
with the plasma membrane
and then this actually
cross-association is quite important for
its function and there's actually a
vesicle next to it which actually has
some distance to these plasma membranes
these are also important but uh this
five nanometer difference between these
vesicles and the vesicle next next to it
to the plasma membrane is actually quite
important for how scientific translation
actually happens and graham is going to
talk more about this topic
but as you can see in these images
electromicroscopy can allow you to look
at these organelles
that
that you cannot see otherwise and so
electromicroscopy is really good at
looking at structures
within themselves
and so to summarize what
electromicroscopy is good for is really
looking at the membrane and organelle
organization and then looking at the
protein localization because below the
diffraction limit i told you about the
fourier microscopy but there's also
immuno electromicrosis that you can use
and this is also good at just good at
looking at the structure of
protein complexes especially with the
cryo-electronic microscopy these days
so what's not
good with direct microscopy is to
looking at the whole cells of tissues i
mean it's possible but this actually
requires reconstruction which is time
consuming
and this is also not good for looking at
the light tissue or looking at the
change in the membrane morphology over
time
and grant is going to address how we can
actually look at the membrane dynamics
on the millisecond time scale
by using a technique for flashing freeze
or stepping foot
okay and so i hope that i was able to
convince you that the electron
microscope is really great at looking at
the structures and
things that we care about
so
but why do we have to use the high
pressure freezing and so the reason for
this is quite simple and this is because
we are using electrons as a source of
imaging and so uh here's the tissue
the electron
electromicroscopy kind of works like the
x-ray or your broken bonds for example
uh and so we are basically um trying to
cast the shadows of electron dense
materials so that we can image this uh
whatever biological tissue you have on
the film or the camera right now the
problem with the electron though is that
electron can get scattered
with any molecules that you have on the
path and so any for example
water molecules that are
in
in a column and this is going to
interfere with the incident electrons
and therefore you cannot have electrons
that can be used to image your tissues
and so in order to avoid this um
electromicro microscope is operated
under the vacuum this is actually
um this is actually bad for uh
biological tissues because biological
tissues are usually hydrated
and what this means is that you have to
actually dehydrate tissues in order to
image them under the microscope and so
um
you can think of a situation like a
grape and resin and so if you dehydrate
a grape basically it's going to look
like reason uh so as you can see the
morphology of grape is stored distorted
in this case
and so in order to avoid this uh what
people typically do is to fix structures
using aldehyde-based fixatives right um
and so you can actually proceed with
tissues having a cross-linked molecules
and so that you can retain the certain
structures
but this is still not good enough and so
in fact uh this example from graham
notices lab i'm basically looking at the
brain slices from
mouse and what you can see is that the
fresh tissue uh comparing fresh tissue
to the chemical fixed tissues you can
see the size difference
you are basically shrinking tissue
basically by just
chemical fixing tissue
and so this is still not good enough
right and so what you want to do is to
be able to retain tissues um
in
its original morphology and so
the only way to get out of this is
basically freeze those tissues so that
we can actually keep them in in
a in an original form
breathing tissue though is going to be a
little bit of problem and the reason for
this is that as you know the water
molecules uh when you try to freeze
what's going to happen is that it's kind
of for my
hexagonal
ice crystals and then they basically
expand right and so when the ice crystal
expands then what's going to happen is
it's going to basically break the
tissues apart
and also another thing that happens here
when the ice crystal forms is that all
the solutes like proteins and salts is
going to be excluded from the
ice crystals such that the local osmotic
stress is going to be different i mean
this also
basically can break the tissues apart
and so
because of all of this you have to avoid
aspects of permissions
and then in order to do this there are a
few ways that uh that we have come up
with
like what i mean by
we
the researchers of the
um decades basically uh came up with is
basically the way to uh
freeze tissues without that crystal
formation and there are largely three
ways to
freeze tissues without that ice crystal
formation the first technique is kind of
like making an ice cream
and basically you have to add cryo
protecting into the tissue and so you
can use tissues with you know sugar or
milk
for like making ice cream basically like
you can add a lot of sugar and then
preserve tissues
and so when you eat ice cream there's no
this uh crystal like um texture uh it's
because there's no ice crystals forming
ice cream
and so you can do that in the biological
tissues by basically nuking tissues with
the sugar and this is called toxic toxic
method and people use this for doing a
rectum uh the immunoglobulin microscopy
the second way to basically avoid and
ice crystal formation
is to use the
uh basically it's kind of like making a
dipping dots where you reduce the volume
of the tissue that you're freezing and
increasing the freezing rate and so as
you know the different doses made by
made by liquid nitrogen by basically
dipping small bits of
ice cream
and then although this doesn't have a
milk in it uh you still don't have this
uh ice cream you know the like crystal
crystalline like
texture when you eat different dogs and
people use this technique for basically
single particle cryo-em or cryo-electron
tomography these days
this is called planche readings and so
we are basically putting the tissues or
uh samples into liquid
in those cases
the third way to get around this ice
crystal issue is to make the water
sluggish and this is the super queen
effect that we are talking about and
this is what the high pressure freezing
actually does
and so how
the way that the hydration reason
actually works is basically making a
water sliding so that they're
they don't have time
to actually really rearrange into the
hexagonal ice as you freeze tissue so
that the water molecules basically stays
where they are as you freeze them uh
using liquid nitrogen and this is what
we are actually doing by applying high
pressure onto the tissues uh 2000
atmospheric pressure uh using the light
uh in this case like a high pressure
freezer
and then what we do is we come in with
the liquid nitrogen to basically freeze
tissue
instantaneously and then with this
approach we can retain the tissue
integrity uh without basically
compromising the methodology and so here
is an example image and this is the same
silica mental knob code that i showed
you earlier on the right side with the
high pressure breathing but if you look
at the conventional aldehyde fixed
tissues but you see that there's
actually all all these tissues are there
but if you look at the morphology uh the
neurons are more like
jigsaw pablo and if you look at the
mitochondria in muscle tissues and they
you know their membrane is kind of like
a
laplace and so the morphology is really
different from what you see on the right
and this is also true in the mouse brain
tissues and this is the example image
from graham nausea again and then what
you can see here is that
what you're losing in these tissues is
this extracellular space and so normally
in a brain tissues there there should be
a lot of extra several space
but when you're using a chemical effects
um
you can see that there's no not much of
the extra steroid space
using this technique uh using a high
pressure freezing technique we can also
preserve protein localization or um
protein organization over the structures
of
membrane much better
and this is actually recently
demonstrated by our heteroscope
using fixed plus chemical fixed tissues
of endoplasmic reticulum and that they
are looking at here and as you can see
if you do not given a fluorescence
microscopy you can tell that the
chemical fixation is totally changing
the morphology of all these organelles
that you want to look at and so high
pressure freezing basically
prevents or
avoids all these artifacts that i
described
then you can look you can retain the
morphology of the tissues
and so this is why we want to use high
pressure freezing and then
this is actually quite important for
looking at the membrane morphology using
electromicroscopy
and so now i'm going to hand this over
to grant cusick who is going to talk
about uh how we can actually add a
temporal dimension to electromicroscopy
because all of these samples that you
are looking at is basically a static
image of tissues that are fixed or
frozen and so
grant
take it over
uh thanks very much shigeki
so yeah i'm grant a phd candidate in
chicago's lab and i'm going to talk
about how we can combine the nanometer
resolution of electron microscopy with
millisecond precision of high pressure
freezing to look at membrane dynamics at
synapses
so in the whatnabe lab we're very
interested in synaptic cell biology
and so shigeki already showed you an
example of this beautiful structure that
we see
and just looking at a synapse you can
sort of understand why this is a
structure that is traditionally in the
domain of electron microscopy and that's
really just because everything is very
very small
here looking at it the entire
pre-synaptic terminal is only about a
micron across synaptic vesicles are 40
nanometers in diameter and tightly
packed together and all these sort of
fine structures of synaps vesicles
getting close to the active zone
vesicles fusing things endocytosing
things endocytosing in the free snaps
all this is at a nanometer scale really
only accessible to electron microscopy
under most conditions
but the issue here is that as shigeki
said electron microscopy is
really good and only really good at
looking at dead tissue and not at
dynamic processes but the synapse is not
only obviously quite dynamic but
operating at a time scale really not
seen anywhere else in biology so we're
operating in a spatial scale of
nanometers which is good for em but
we're also operating a temporal scale of
as fast as milliseconds
um and so what we've wanted to do and
what we do in the lab is combine uh
temporal resolution with uh
spatial resolution to capture these
events using high pressure freezing
and so in principle with high pressure
freezing this is very possible because
it intrinsically has to be a fast
process that's part of how you get your
beautiful structure preserved
so the emis the current leica instrument
that we use
your actual control of freezing is down
to the millisecond so the high pressure
freezing there in addition to giving you
native structure gives you some of that
temporal precision by itself
so what you need then the next step you
need to look at these uh synaptic
processes is a way to precisely
stimulate the cells to couple that
stimulation that induction of action
potentials and activity with your
freezing
and so the way that shigeki and others
have developed this
starting over 10 years ago is initially
using a system that they named zap flash
and freeze
um so the freeze obviously comes from
high pressure freezing the flash comes
from the fact that you're using light to
stimulate the cells
and so in this system
they use a molecule that will be
familiar to any of the neuroscientists
here channelrhodopsin
um so at the time this was developed
channelrhodopsin was a hot new
technology in neuroscience uh which is
widely used because it allows you to by
expressing it in neurons
you can make excitable cells like
neurons excitable with light
because channelrhodopsin is a light
gated cation channel
and that means if you express it in a
neuron and then you shine light on the
neuron that channel adoption will open
sodium ions will
flow in and that will trigger an action
potential
uh so if you can think about how you
could set this up for your high pressure
freezing experiment you have your cells
already moved into the high pressure
freezing chamber all you need is a
little led light shined in
uh so in this case you shine a led light
for 10 milliseconds and that usually
triggers a single action potential
uh when that happens you get what you
want you get activity you get an action
potential that will flow into the
synapse
and then trigger all the kind of things
you want to see vesicles will fuse
release neurotransmitter it will be
received by the postsynapse you'll see
endocytosis all the kind of things we
want to look at
and then at exactly the time point you
want where you think you're going to see
the thing you want to see you freeze the
cell immobilize it immediately and then
once it's frozen everything is frozen in
time essentially forever and then you
can go look at what it looked like in
that instant by electron microscopy
so this is just showing an example of
essentially how you set that up all that
fancy work of things being very fast and
you know the stimulation all that that's
all done by the machine all we really do
is uh set up your uh um
sandwich of solution that goes around
the cells close the cover and then
everything the machine takes over
everything from there
again flashing the cells and then
freezing them
so it's all just based on what you've
programmed into the machine
so uh all the data i'm going to show you
today are all from the main model system
we work on in the nibely lab mice
and specifically dissociated mouse
hippocampal neurons
but i do want to note um
that these sort of procedures are
applicable and have been applied by
shigeki and others
to a variety of different model systems
in neuroscience so essentially anything
that's thin enough uh to high pressure
freeze which is quite a lot of things so
organotypic or acute slices can be done
with this
as well as small organ entire organisms
like c elegans or
fly larvae
so when we do flash and freeze we can
see some cool stuff so we can actually
capture what's going on with the synapse
during neurotransmission so for example
you can actually see synaptic vesicles
this process that happens in hundreds of
microseconds to milliseconds these
synaptic vesicles that have fused with
the plasma membrane and are now
collapsed having their membrane collapse
into the plasma membrane
um
critically what shigeki discovered in
his big breakthrough that was enabled by
this technology
is he found an entirely new pathway for
endocytosis
that because it happens on the scale of
hundreds of milliseconds it's by far the
fastest form of endocytosis that occurs
in any cell and it's as far as we know
unique to synapses uh was termed ultra
fast into cytosis um so this advance in
technology uh with flash and freeze and
high pressure freezing really has blown
the entire field of synaptic vessel
endocytosis and sort of uh completely
redefined the dogma and rewritten the
textbooks
but what i'm going to talk about for the
rest of today is my focus which is on
synaptic vesicle docking and exocytosis
and how some of that work has been
enabled by the next step in the new
generation of uh stimula of
time-resolved electron microscopy zap
and freeze
uh so in shigeki's experiments i showed
how you can see synaptic vesicles that
have fused um so it's always been
considered in the field
that the vesicles that are available to
so a
pre-snapped terminal is filled with all
these hundreds of vesicles but the ones
that are actually ready to fuse are what
are shown here as docked vesicles
so docking is again something you can
only get by electron microscopy this is
a strict morphological definition of a
vesicle that is in contact with the
plasma membrane so here shigeki in this
micrograph is showing the very strict
definition if you're only a few
nanometers away that vesicle's not
thought it's really only those vesicles
that are in contact again
something you can only see by electron
microscopy with cryofix tissue that are
docked and actually ready to fuse
um so shigeki was the one who actually
showed that this prediction is really
correct because when you stimulate you
can see that when you get exocytosis
only these dot vesicles are depleted so
these uh slightly further away tethered
vesicles or not it's really the dark
vesicles that fuse and get used up
so this is actually quite a potent
effect just from this one action
potential so after holding a single
action potential almost 40 to 50 percent
of all your dot vesicles across all your
synapses are gone
uh and uh this is consistent with sort
of the thinking about synapses which is
that it's well established that as you
stimulate the synapse they get exhausted
they do what's known as depression and
this all makes sense together because as
you're stimulating you're using up dot
vesicles there's less substrates for
neurotransmitter release you're going to
release an estro transmitter the synapse
is going to depress
and shigeki showed that um
synaptic vesicle uh docking recovery
occurs on about the time scale of
seconds so for in these preparations for
vesicles to get fully back to baseline
takes about 10 seconds
um
so this generally gels with what people
know about synapses you know vesicles
get used up they get weaker as you
stimulate
uh but any physiologist will tell you uh
that actually many synapses on very fast
time scales on these millisecond time
scales actually increase their outputs
and get stronger
and so here looking at typical
electrophysiology data looking at the
outputs of the postsynaptic cell this is
a very characteristic behavior of many
synapses where if you pair two stimuli
very closely together so you stimulate
once and then and you get a certain
response and say you stimulate again 10
milliseconds afterwards much of the time
you actually get a much stronger
response from the synapse so it's
actually at these closer time points to
your first stimuli you get your
strongest responses
which is weird because those are the
time points where you're uh you've lost
these vesicles and they haven't
recovered yet they take way longer than
this to recover from the data that we
have
so the way people normally think about
this in the field is that all right you
have fewer vesicles there uh but somehow
the vesicles that are remaining become
more likely to fuse so you're
essentially making up for this lack of
vesicles with sort of the remaining ones
picking up the slack
there are a lot of limitations uh to
this idea not least that as you have
fewer vesicles and the vesicles
remaining are more and more likely to
fuse you would expect the synapse to
just really exhaust itself out which
again they don't do synapses many
synapses can keep firing for a long
period of time
uh so what we thought about is i mean
it's a in principle a very simple idea
well what if you just have recovery of
vesicles that's quicker you have
vesicles that dock in really quickly
uh but again this isn't what shigeki saw
with his experiments right docking took
about 10 seconds to come back
but here again we come to a technical
limitation which is that while flash and
freeze by itself is really impressive um
at this time scale actually there could
still be things we're missing
and that's because while the high
pressure freezing as i said is extremely
precise down to about the millisecond um
channelrhodopsin itself as a tool has a
lot of limitations and potential
artifacts you introduce the most
relevant one uh to this being that your
temporal resolution is somewhat limited
i said we had to shine a light for about
10 milliseconds the action potential can
fire any time within that 10
milliseconds and even afterwards so
essentially we're limiting our tempo
resolution down to 10 milliseconds so
within all those precise delicate events
that are happening over the course of
milliseconds uh we really could be
missing those with this technique
um so to sort of overcome this obstacle
uh wayne davis and the engineers that
leica came up with in principle a very
similar solution which is well why don't
you just electrically stimulate the
neurons that's what they normally
respond to they're electrically
excitable cells uh so the problem here
is that uh shoving a bunch of wires into
a high pressure freezer that's then
going to go to 2000 atmospheres is not a
good idea
so the solution they came up with is to
use the same light stimulation system
but instead of having the light
stimulate the cells you have the light
trigger a photoelectric circuit um so
here's sort of the basic setup of what
we term zap and freeze and the principle
by which it works essentially you just
have a um
a capacitor that's charged up uh
and
closed by a uh a photoelectric switch so
at when this is charged up the neurons
aren't being stimulated you charge it up
everything goes into the high pressure
freezer
and then once in there everything works
just like it does in flash and freeze
except now your light shines onto that
photoelectric cell that closes the
circuit and then and you just shine the
light for a millisecond boom those cells
get zapped for a millisecond and then
just like with fraction freeze you can
then freeze your cells at whatever time
point you want five milliseconds a
second 10 seconds whatever you like
and so yeah we call this zap and freeze
and really all this requires is just a
few extra add-ons to your high-pressure
freezer you just need this light
stimulation system that shines the led
in like with flash and freeze uh and
then you just need a charging system
that charges these little middle plates
that you get that work much like any
other kind of uh setup that you would
have for uh for high pressure freezing
and this enables you to electrically
control your electrically excitable
cells
and just a quick note here all these
things are very fancy and do seem you
know this is a real technical advance
but on the side of the experimentalist
it really doesn't add any extra
difficulty to a high pressure freezing
experiment
really everything on my end is very much
the same all you have to do is just set
everything up you close the cover on the
machine and then it goes in
so there really is no added special
technique on the part of you're the
experimentalist to doing a zap and
freeze experiment in fact i find this to
be one of the easiest configurations to
work with despite the marvelous results
that you'll see that we get out of it
so when we do zap and freeze uh much as
with flash and freeze uh we can capture
synaptic vesicle exocytosis and see
vesicles that have fused
um
we can even uh do cool stuff like for
example do serial sectioning which
shigeki mentioned earlier to get a 3d
view of the entire synapse and we can
capture things like one synapse that has
lots of different fusions all throughout
them so we can really capture these
events very precisely
so now we come back to our question that
we wanted to answer which is what's
going on with the dot vesicles how does
that relate to the synaptic output and
so now with this really precise temporal
resolution what we can do is we want to
sort of walk forward and see what's
going on millisecond by millisecond as
this uh paired pulse plasticity sets in
you know are the you know as vegetables
we know are depleted at first are they
actually coming back or is it really
just the remaining vesicles that are
doing the work
so the way we do this is we walk forward
every three milliseconds uh for our
freezing time point so our earliest time
point that we freeze at uh which i
showed you there where we capture
exocytosis readily uh is five
milliseconds there are just some
physical limitations your temporal
resolution is down to a millisecond but
there essentially it takes a certain
amount of time just for liquid nitrogen
to actually freeze the cell so for pure
physical limits five milliseconds is the
earliest you can go
uh and then walk out from there
as this plasticity sets in and then also
freeze after it uh at say 100
milliseconds or a second or 10 seconds
after we know that synapses have gone
back down to baseline
and so when we do that here's what we
get when quantifying doc vesicles
uh so as before you can see that our
vesicles are quite profoundly depleted
by only a single action potential
and that's more or less maintained as we
go forward until we get to 14
milliseconds and it always is 14
milliseconds
whereas if by magic your vesicles were
bound completely back to baseline so the
synapse says within this very brief time
period completely recovered all the doc
vesicles it's completely
indistinguishable from our no stem
control
so this was really wild you know this
was not really what we were expecting to
see because this happened a thousand
fold faster than what shigeki had
previously seen with flash and freeze um
and so the first thought was like yeah
things are crazy different what's going
on well you know it could be that this
temporal resolution again we just missed
it before and everything else is the
same and indeed when you freeze it
further at time points we get the same
kind of results you got with flash and
freeze so if you freeze at 100
milliseconds vesicles are actually back
down again
and then as before it takes about 10
seconds for the vesicles to again
restore the baseline
so what we discovered with this
technical advance with zap and freeze is
that dot vessel recovery at synapses
actually occurs in two phases um the
first of which is extraordinarily fast
on the millisecond time scale which we
term transient docking because those
vesicles dock in but then they pop off
and undock and then it takes a while for
vesicles to again then be restored
and so this has become a uh really sort
of hot topic in the field there's a lot
of things you can imagine about how
these very fast vesicle dynamics can
affect synaptic outputs and this has all
been really enabled by this system
uh so that's the end of the data um what
i will say is that uh especially when
we're talking about plasticity many of
you neuroscientists here might be saying
well everything was just done with
single action potentials and that's true
we always tend to start with that simple
case of just stimulating once and then
seeing what happens
but really this system is amenable to
any kind of electrophysiology experiment
you could possibly design any kind of
train stimulation ltp lcd any kind of
weird protocol of stimulation you could
possibly imagine with whatever amount of
action potentials with whatever time
point you can all do that with a high
pressure producer and i have done things
like that i've done lots of complex kind
of stimuli all you have to do is
essentially just program that into the
freezer you just use the touchscreen to
tap it in and then you can really look
at whatever kind of process you can
possibly imagine neurobiologically
and so yeah that's really what uh this
time-resolved electron microscopy has
allowed us to do
with this technical advance we've
discovered these new processes that had
not been seen before and we really
hadn't been expecting because nobody
could look at these kind of things
before
like ultra fast endocytosis uh transient
docking uh being able to directly
visualize synaptic vesicle exocytosis
and endocytosis and so with this system
you can really do the same you can say
you know i want to look at this mutant i
want to look at this simulation protocol
this plasticity paradigm
and then you just do your experiment and
the wonderful thing is you never know
what you'll see under an electron
microscope i haven't talked at all about
the postsynapse there's lots of things
you can capture there you really never
know what you're going to see and you uh
really will wait to see what you can get
at this beautiful amount of resolution
with this temporal component added
and so with that uh i want to thank you
all for for being here and listening and
i want to thank everybody that made this
work possible
not least uh particularly essential to
my work uh where sumana and kaye in the
lab and i also want to shout out tyler
who's my good friend and also the one
other guy obsessed with docking in the
lab
uh and also of course uh the wonderful
engineers at leica as well as wayne
davis uh who all built these wonderful
toys that i get to play with uh and
everybody for uh and labyrinths for
organizing this um and with that we'll
take any questions
thank you shigeki and grant for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for
all right let's get started our first
question asks
are there any artifacts introduced by
high pressure freezing
okay i can take this
question and so this is actually quite a
difficult question to answer
but i can tell you that there's
some artifacts that you may actually get
based on
damage from ice crystal formations so
when the ice crystal forms then you can
get a membrane breaks as i
presented
and you do actually see some evidence of
that when you actually look through the
images and so you do get some sort of
artifact
and so um i mean you know you try your
best to avoid the ice crystal formations
but
that could happen
but besides that um i don't think high
pressure itself is actually doing
anything to the cells while they're
actually being frozen we have some
evidence of that um but
nothing that we can share at the moment
thank you
our next question um looks like this one
is for grant it asks is it possible to
test that the simulation is working with
flash and freeze and zap and freeze
uh yeah so for
uh flash this is
relatively trivial in the senses it's
the same kind of controls you do for any
other channel red ops experiment you
know you just have whatever your
configuration is whatever your
preparation is expressing
channelrhodopsin uh you know do the same
stimulation you do for flash and freeze
but do your e-fits recordings the same
kind of thing you'd normally do for uh
to measure action potentials for general
reduction for zap and freeze it's a
little trickier because
unlike unlike flash and freeze where
you're just doing channel adoption
simulation the the field simulation is a
specific configuration
um so the the zap itself as it works in
the instrument only happens in this
closed sandwich in this closed thing
that's not accessible to ifas obviously
because it's a closed system you can't
put any electrodes in there um
and not really accessible optically to
things like measuring directly measuring
action potentials um that being said
there are two ways around that that
we've gotten around that so you can do
some other meth so we've stimulated
cells for example directly in the
uh with the system and then
um done some less precise experiments
just to check that you get activity so
for example you can do fm dye so we did
that we stimulated them in the machine
then instead of freezing them we do fm
dye
uh we uh uh fix them and then do fm die
imaging after that uh i think other
people have done stuff like calcium
imaging to check that it's working um
but if you want to really directly
measure your action pencils and say you
know i'm getting the exact pattern of
action potential that i want to uh you
can just use a uh field simulation
configuration of the same type you know
with the same field strength that kind
that you'd use for uh live imaging or
ephes recordings like that as a point of
comparison
all right thank you grant we have
another question here looks like this
one is directed towards you as well
this one asks when do you use the flash
and freeze method versus the zapping
freeze
uh yeah so so i focused on in my case
where zap and freeze was uh enabling of
the technology over flash and freeze
because of the um added temporal
precision uh so obviously that's not
going to apply to all experiments uh you
know much of the time you won't be
freezing at these kind of very so if you
want to look at transient docking you
got to do zap that's as far as we know
what what we know right now but for
other things especially if you're
freezing at longer time points
everything looks little for example
we've investigated ultra fast under
cytosis with zap and it looks just like
it does with flash
um
if you're using the same system i was
showing culture hippocampal neurons that
just seems like the easier thing you
don't have to worry about generatops and
you don't have to do any of that it's
just a simpler system
uh where flash can be really important
is obviously it gives you all the kind
of advantages that you get uh with
channelrhodopsin in neuroscience
generally that is if you're working in
an intact organism or you're working in
slices and you want to stimulate
specific pathways and know what you're
trying you know stimulate specific
neurons then you're obviously going to
use flash so it's going to be good for a
lot of systems like that um because
apart from the sort of things i
discussed the differences are mostly uh
subtle it's just going to be what's the
best for your system in terms of what
you're trying to investigate
great thank you looks like we have time
for one more question here and this is a
two-part question so this asks can this
high-pressure method be used for every
type of cell and can it get these
beautiful images from every type of cell
or is their cell favorite types
okay so
yeah and technically speaking you can
use this technique to look at any types
of cells
the only issue is that there's actually
a limit to
the thickness of the tissue that you can
breathe
and so typically this is supposed to be
about 200 micrometer and that basically
minimizes the
ice crystal formation and then you get
you know pretty decent images um
decent preservation of tissues
out of those samples
um
yeah so yeah you can use any type of any
types of cells
um and can you get beautiful images from
every type of cell so this is actually
an interesting question because it
really depends on the users
and so you have to really practice on
loading the samples handling the samples
in order to get a beautiful images and
so it takes quite quite a bit of
practice
but once you get used to doing a
breathing uh i think it's gonna be you
know
yeah this technique is to work and we
can always get good images
great well thank you again shigeki and
grant for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank labrutz and our sponsor like leica
microsystems for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye
you